what is going on boys and girls I got to
zoom in on my face so you know who it is
what's going on but uh yeah beginning
episode five we have 34.6 mil if you
guys didn't see the last episode I'd
highly recommend it if you guys want to
start from the beginning the series feel
free to do that but uh yeah we're going
to get on into it so what I have to do
right now I have to make some odium
Wards sell off some ancient pages and do
a black demon task is what we have on
the uh list of things to do also got to
do some quests uh I start these on
Fridays and my kind of motto is is
weekend is time for questing since I'm
only at what like 94 is yeah 94 Quest
points I definitely need to work on that
all right so there we go along black
demon task later and we are done 76
almost 7 or 75 almost 76 strength there
we go also got 60 Slayer I don't know
what that unlocks in particular but no
abber inspectors that's not bad at all
uh Cave wh is also unlocked probably
should do the Quest for that here soon
just so I can you know just say that I
can do them but there we go 81 and
that'll be a pretty quick task and some
easy points I think I'm closing in
actually on getting my Slayer Helm yeah
400 and I'm at 240 or 346 so we're on
our way although I do have to get two
crafting levels but whatever all right
it is late at night not really that late
I'm just getting tired so I might start
grinding or I might just go to bed and
oh [__] Christ all right pretty big
milestone I feel like I'll just go and
kill the baby ones and
uh there we go so I have the uh ability
to make it I don't know if there's any
crafting boost in the game but I'm just
going to go ahead and and get 55 because
leveling up stuff is something I'm going
to have to do anyway so I might as well
all right sometimes I like to make dumb
and really stupid risks so I'm going to
go ahead and uh you know just do all
these mal addiction and odium shards and
one go so uh if I end up dying I'm going
to be able to keep 12.8 mil or yeah I'll
be able to keep that but if I uh you
know end up dying I will lose this so uh
little bit of a risk I guess you could
say all right so I'd say a safe estimate
on all this would be about 200 250k
profit off of each one so we made about
800k to a mill it's kind of hard to keep
track of though since there's just
constantly like offers coming in and out
and I'm always changing which uh ward in
particular I'm doing and there is the
level 55 crafting so this means that we
can make up our own black mask or not
black mask but Slayer mask which is
pretty cool so I'm going to go ahead and
uh pick out all the stuff in my bank and
then we'll make it I'm actually
impressed with myself I was able to
remember everything I needed so there we
go and
boom there we go Slayer helmet so that
is huge as far as I mean this all goes
87 combats not too bad to get a Slayer
level I wouldn't say so go out and take
a picture for the thumbnail that's way
too close all right this should be the
end of the quest holy [__] I did not
know that this Quest gave you six Quest
points that's insane so we just hit the
100 Mark which is really nice I'm going
to go ahead and do a Holy Grail Quest
now but uh yeah not too shabby all right
here we go finishing off the holy rail
Quest this will get get us a uh prayer
level which pretty cool and uh yeah
other than that up to 102 Quest points
so not too shabby all right there we go
lost tribe Quest is done another Quest
point a little bit of mining XP and uh
moving on up all right so a small little
merch that I got going on while I am a
questing is just these armadel page sets
so uh I'm gaining
about 240k or so off of uh just putting
these into page set so it's not too
shabby at all so I'll do that whenever I
can I'm trying to buy up some addiction
WS right now just to be able to make
them but more so be able to make a guide
on them so once those are done we'll
have a little bit more money to put into
other stuff but until then this is what
we got all right there we go another
easy Quest done so trial totem is
finished 104 Quest points uh Hey 29
thiing as well there we go and there we
go death to the D gungon Quest is done
another Quest Point little bit of XP
might get a yeah two thieving levels off
of that which is pretty nice all right
so here we go this could be the end of
the clue scroll if you guys noticed any
difference in my voice change the
settings on my mic should be pretty
decent now so three is the answer to
that and [__] me and let me guess I'm
not going to be able to do this one all
right there we go a hard clue done which
is pretty surprising because on this
account I you know don't often get to
finish hard Clues and I mean we'll take
it we'll take it it's not too bad it's
like your average clue so that's nice
though all right so I went ahead and did
a little bit of nightmare Zone before
this blue dragon T I kind of want to do
range but uh I realized that I need a
imbued Slayer Helm so what went ahead
and did some merchesi did a little bit
of nightmare Zone uh got a 800 Kish
margin on ring of coins which is insane
I also made 120k off of party hats and
specs so that was you know about a mill
merch just in total just chilling there
so I had to just die and come back and
uh reflip the
merchesi Hat in specs for 1.23 five so I
made 5 30k off of selling in that um as
far as the samurai hat I made around
200k off of that and then the Ring of
coins I went ahead and made nine or I
think yeah practically a mill off of
that so all these merch is combined
right here once I collect it is 1.7 mil
profit so that's really nice going to go
ahead and uh I think I'm going to go to
bed I mean there's some really good
margins right now but I kind of just
want to go to sleep all right so to kind
of talk about what
merchesi did another ring of coins that
merge for about 1.1 mil overnight um on
top of that I tried to do a Dragon
Hunter crossbow I lost a little under
400k so like
360k is off of that um at the time of me
buying this it said it'd be around a 1.4
mil profit but apparently a lot of
people got in on this and I was just
happy to sell it off for a loss I didn't
really care all that much and then right
now I'm doing Dragon harpoons as you
guys can see I'm making about 600k off
of each one of these and I already have
one sold off which is really good so
hopefully I can can buy another one and
we can kind of merge these just for a
little bit since they have a pretty
decent margin they buy and sell
relatively quick all right and there we
go we got nature Spirit Quest done I
don't think I get any levels off of this
no I don't get any do
I no I don't get any levels but uh it is
kind of nice 107 Quest points and now I
can do fairy tale part one which will
unlock fairy rings which are going to be
really useful just in general and also
for Clues so I'm going to go ahead and
do that Quest now also really doing it
so I can get 17 farming kind of start up
with that I kind of want start doing
herb runs quite often and another Quest
done so this one was a fairy tale Quest
got two Quest points but more
importantly 17 farming indeed that is a
ton of levels to get closing in on
1.25kg us one like world but
realistically everyone can go there so
that is what it is uh going to go ahead
and start working on farming now and uh
get fairy rings so that's cool all right
so a little commentary over what's going
on here sorry if you can hear anything
in the background but we got a blood
Feld task went ahead and did that so
then we came back and fire Giants I was
just on my Slayer grind you guys can see
I got a lot of stuff actually on the
blood F task like 600 Bloods which is
pretty sweet then I finished up a hard
clue scroll and went ahead and got
absolutely nothing all right so there we
go went ahead and got another task we
got hellhound just finished up with my
fire Giants got two piece of the totem
which is pretty nice so on the
hellhounds task right now got another
dark totem piece that'll be our first
actual full totem which would be really
nice we got a hard clue scroll just got
77 strength just got 63 Slayer we're
really making some progress on this and
I'm pretty excited for it um the reason
I've been doing so much Slayers CU just
because I've been doing a lot of
homework I still have a lot of homework
to do today so I'm just going to be
afking some stuff that's really afkable
while I do
that all right just finished up that
steel dragons task that was freaking
terrible that took forever and there we
go 76 Anu so that's not too bad at all
should be pretty quick um I'm going to
go downstairs actually and work on my
computer science homework though so uh
I'm going to be AFK in that while I do
that so I won't be able to record but
you guys will see me after that task
probably during the next one all right
so then I went ahead and got another
task we ended up getting greater demons
greater demon test pretty chill and at
this point I was up to 68 defense on my
way to tags and uh went ahead and got
another one we're also at 64 Slayer more
Hells literally just nonstop in the
catacombs but we ended up getting 70
defense on that task and then we were
back again for another task per usual
more blood felds all right so Live come
for the first time in a while but uh
we're up to almost 74 attack we're at 65
Slayer which isn't too bad 77 HP we got
on that task 92 combat in total let's
see what task we get now more hellhounds
that's perfectly fine with me really
afkable great task all right so there we
go hellhounds task is done almost well I
guess not almost but we're a little over
halfway to 75 attack that's where I'm
going to stop with that for a while I
kind of want to get my strength up and
start to maybe make some like pking
videos on this account eventually but
there we go 142 blood felds
realistically I'm just getting a ton of
tasks that I can do in the catacombs
which is great um this task I was able
to get just a couple more pieces I
already have one totem built which is
pretty cool um I think I'm going to go
lower my prices on these on these van
braces though because I kind of wanted
to sell them off and right now I
wouldn't lose any money I'd actually
probably make a m to two mil first Farm
run I'd say it was a
[Music]
success all right I feel like literal
[__] right now but this is where we are
with uh with everything so I sold off
the mal addiction Wards I probably made
about 300 350k off each one so I made
about 1.5 mil there which is really nice
but uh just going to go and chill out
now kind of show you guys the bank right
now and just kind of have an update as
far as where I'm at I guess MoneyWise
because I don't do that all too much uh
I don't know what just happened but I'm
going to go ahead and go on conduit now
and check and see what my bank value is
so Bank value
calculate and uh yeah it said right now
my bank is 46.2 MIL which is absolutely
insane all right so we've gotten two
levels on this task already we went
ahead and just got 75 attack there a
second ago I think that's where I'm
going to stop off with the attack for a
while and then just got 66 Slayer too
all right so just got done with my blood
felds task this is actually pretty
decent merch I'm hoping I can cash in on
so Anu stuff has always just had the
craziest margins because there's barely
any of it in the game and people just
like to wear it around and stuff so the
inq socks I just bought on for 16
apparently I can sell them on for about
18.6 but I'm going to try to sell them
on for 18.2 considering these things
really don't sell and by that often so
I'd be much more happier just getting it
out for you know 400k under what I could
get it for than not being able to sell
it on at all uh mal addiction charge
three I haven't been able to buy it all
so I'm going to have to up the price on
that though all right here we are going
to get another test so the blood felon
task was all right but I'm hoping for
something a little better 176 dagaut
I'll take that that's not a bad task at
all all right so from there I ended up
doing just a lot of uh winter top really
no reason but here's just kind of a
little crate opening I did in the
background I think I had a few more that
were unpictured but I did end up getting
some fir making levels and a wood
cutting level which is pretty sweet but
I think we're up to about 40 KC here now
and we only have one piece which is a
little depressing but we're definitely
working on it all right just woke up and
this is probably one of the better
in the series so Anu socks just sold for
18.2 mil and as you guys can see I
bought them for 16 that's a 2.2 mil
profit on an item that only took me
about 12 hours to merge so that's just
crazy um mal addiction Awards aren't
buying I got my offer on that but that
is an insane profit and I'm hoping to do
that again the Anu stuff merges really
well so we'll see if I can do it again
shout out to this guy what's going on
bro all right so here we are did a
little merch wasn't intentional at first
because you know me being the guy that I
am I went ahead and bought a strength
weapon and I saw that there was a 270k
margin I was like wow just got screwed
out of that so I went and merch three so
I ended up making 540k in total after
you subtract the loss so yeah wasn't
going down like that all right so a
little bit more uh postom but it is what
it is we end up getting a trolls task
which you know I mean it is what it is
you work your way through those but
beforehand I figured I'd go ahead and
get some mal addiction WS made about
250k to 300K profit off of each one of
these so definitely worth the time so
after that we end up going back and uh
getting an assignment from NE ended up
getting iron dragons kind of a [__] task
but you know you do what you can and you
uh you just tredge through it from there
some more black demons those aren't too
terrible and aberin spectors but I ended
up going to sell off a bunch of mal
addiction WS later I ended up making 2
mil on those which is insane all right
so from there we go ahead and go back to
NE we unlock Superior foes which is
pretty cool and uh yeah that's about it
back into the live comom all right so
there we go done with the abber
inspector task pretty good pretty good
and all so almost 79 strength and uh
getting on our way to 68 Slayer this is
going to be the last test I get for the
video so 48 steals we'll start off the
next video with that but I'm going to go
ahead find our bank value and we're
going to end off this video and get on
into the next one all right so there we
go we are here at the bank um I'm not
going to take out all this stuff just
cuz I I know what it's worth 22.6 mil
over here in the GE just buying stuff on
top of that I'm going to go ahead and
calculate my bank and my Bank value
according to the conduit client is 30.5
MIL which means in total we have 53 mil
pretty much which is pretty good so
that'll be it for episode 5 it's pretty
crazy that we're only five episodes in
and I have 53 mil like that just shows
like how crazy the series is um I'm
trying to go for weekly stuff of this
but in the future if you guys want more
episodes there will be a little less
content but I mean there'll be just as
much content but the content would be a
little more different I guess so let me
know below if you guys want to see more
videos probably twice a week but less
like Milestone achievements and more
like me just doing stuff or if you guys
rather have the weekly videos because I
enjoy putting these out and I could
definitely try for two a week so if you
guys enjoyed the video make sure to
leave a like if you guys want to uh
subscribe that'd be very much
appreciated Twitter is in the
description down below and uh yeah other
than that hope you guys have a wonderful
day and peace now time to play some
rainbow six each